Before we get started today, I'd like to ask you to take a moment to fill out our listener survey. We'd like to know more about what you think of this podcast and what you'd like to see us do more of. We'd also like to know more about you. So if you would, please go to our website, www.Speakingof Psychology.org, and click on the link to our listener's survey. It should not take you long to complete. We'd really appreciate it. Now, on to the episode. We first talked about psychedelic therapy on this podcast three years ago. Since then, interest in psychedelics has skyrocketed.
在今天开始之前，我想请大家花点时间填写我们的听众调查问卷。我们想更多地了解您对本播客的看法，以及您希望我们多做些什么。我们也想更多地了解您。如果您愿意，请访问我们的网站 www.SpeakingofPsychology.org，并点击听众调查问卷的链接。完成它应该不会花您太长时间。我们将不胜感激。现在，进入本期节目。我们三年前在播客中首次讨论了迷幻疗法。从那时起，人们对迷幻药的兴趣呈爆炸式增长。
Two states, Oregon and Colorado, have voted to legalize psilocybin use by adults. And just last month, Australia became the first country in the world to recognize psychedelics as medicines. Doctors there will be able to prescribe psilocybin for depression and MDMA, popularly known as Ecstasy or Mali, for post-traumatic stress disorder. Meanwhile, researchers are studying psychedelic treatments for anxiety, addiction, and other behavioral health disorders. So how did these drugs go from being a symbol of the 1960s counterculture to being touted as among the newest, most promising mental health treatments? And does the research back up the hype?
俄勒冈州和科罗拉多州这两个州已经投票通过了成年人使用裸盖菇素的合法化。就在上个月，澳大利亚成为世界上第一个承认迷幻药为药物的国家。那里的医生将能够开具裸盖菇素用于治疗抑郁症，并开具 MDMA（俗称摇头丸或 Mali）用于治疗创伤后应激障碍。与此同时，研究人员正在研究迷幻药治疗焦虑症、成瘾症和其他行为健康障碍的方法。那么，这些药物是如何从 20 世纪 60 年代反主流文化的象征，变成被吹捧为最新、最有希望的心理健康疗法之一的呢？研究结果是否支持这些炒作？
How do psychedelics work in the brain? What have scientists found out about the types of mental health problems they can treat? What's the legal status of these drugs? Are they likely to be approved as medications in the U.S.? And if they are, who will provide these treatments and who will have access to them? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
迷幻药在大脑中是如何起作用的？科学家们发现了它们可以治疗哪些类型的心理健康问题？这些药物的法律地位如何？它们有可能在美国被批准为药物吗？如果获批，谁将提供这些治疗，谁又能获得这些治疗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Albert Garcia-Romeau, a psychologist and a member of the Psychiatry and Behavioral Sciences faculty at the Johns Hopkins University. School of Medicine. He is also a guest researcher at the National Institute on Drug Abuse. Dr. Garcia-Romew studies the effects of psychedelic drugs in humans. His research interests include clinical applications of psychedelics, mindfulness and altered states of consciousness and their underlying neurobiological mechanisms, as well as real-world drug use patterns and impacts on public health. He has also published dozens of research papers and has been widely interviewed in the media on psychedelic research. Dr. Garcia-Romeo, thank you for joining me today.
我今天的嘉宾是阿尔伯特·加西亚-罗梅乌（Albert Garcia-Romeau）博士，他是一位心理学家，也是约翰霍普金斯大学医学院精神病学和行为科学系的教员。他还是美国国家药物滥用研究所的客座研究员。加西亚-罗梅乌博士研究迷幻药对人类的影响。他的研究兴趣包括迷幻药的临床应用、正念和意识改变状态及其潜在的神经生物学机制，以及现实世界中的药物使用模式及其对公共卫生的影响。他还发表了数十篇研究论文，并就迷幻药研究在媒体上接受过广泛采访。加西亚-罗梅乌博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。
Yeah, thank you for having me. I mentioned a couple of drugs in the introduction that our listeners have probably heard of, psilocybin and MDMA. How do you define a psychedelic? What drugs does the term encompass? Can you explain what each of them is and how they're similar and how they're different? That's a lot of questions, and I can teach a whole class about that, but we'll try to go, We'll try to break it down into some of the basic components there. The term psychedelic was actually coined by a psychiatrist named Humphrey Osmond back in 1957,
是的，谢谢邀请。我在介绍中提到了听众可能听说过的两种药物：裸盖菇素和 MDMA。您如何定义迷幻药？这个术语涵盖哪些药物？您能解释一下它们分别是什么，以及它们有何异同吗？这是一个很大的问题，我可以为此专门开一门课，但我们会尝试将其分解为一些基本组成部分。迷幻药（psychedelic）这个词实际上是由一位名叫汉弗莱·奥斯蒙德（Humphrey Osmond）的精神科医生在 1957 年创造的。
and he was interested in drugs like LSD and mescaline, which are what we call classic psychedelics. They're serotonin-2A receptor agonist drugs, and that's just pharmacologically the mechanism. That's the way that they work in the brain, as far as we can tell. Sillus Simon is another one of these classic psychedelics. And so is DMT or dimethyltryptamine, which is found in the human brain as well as many plants and animals, and is found in ayahuasca as well. And so there's a sort of canonical group of what we call classic psychedelics. Most of those are naturally occurring. So, you know, I mentioned mescaline, which is found in peyote cactus and San Pedro cactus.
他当时对 LSD 和麦司卡林等药物很感兴趣，这些药物被称为经典迷幻药。它们是血清素-2A 受体激动剂药物，从药理学机制上讲，这就是它们在大脑中起作用的方式。裸盖菇素是这些经典迷幻药中的另一种。DMT（二甲基色胺）也是如此，它存在于人脑以及许多动植物中，也存在于死藤水中。因此，有一类我们称之为经典迷幻药的典型药物。其中大多数是天然存在的。比如我提到的麦司卡林，它存在于佩奥特仙人掌和圣佩德罗仙人掌中。
I've talked about DMT, which is found in different types of plants and animals. also psilocybin, which is found in about 200 different species of mushrooms that grow all over the world. And then, you know, LSD is sort of the semi-synthetic derivative that came out. That was sort of, you know, brought the psychedelics into the limelight, if you will, during the 20th century. And, you know, you mentioned the counterculture. The LSD was definitely, you know, heavily involved in that period as well. And so that was something that was synthesized in the laboratory. back in 1938 by a chemist named Dr. Albert Hoffman, but it works by the same mechanism as
我谈到了 DMT，它存在于不同类型的动植物中。还有裸盖菇素，它存在于世界各地生长的约 200 种不同的蘑菇中。然后，LSD 是一种半合成衍生物。正是它在 20 世纪将迷幻药带入了公众视野。您提到的反主流文化，LSD 在那个时期确实参与其中。这是由化学家阿尔伯特·霍夫曼（Albert Hoffman）博士于 1938 年在实验室合成的，但它的作用机制与
these other classic psychedelics, this serotonin 2A receptor mechanism. And so we grouped those together. And when Osmond was studying these drugs, or back in the 1950s, they were trying to find a better name for them because people were usually referring to them as psychotomimetics, meaning that they seem to mimic a psychotic state. And after working with these drugs and taking them himself self-experimenting, he didn't feel that that was an accurate label. He felt that there was more to the drug effects than that. And so he and the British author, Humphrey Osmond, were actually going back and forth trying to figure out, you know, how do we call these drugs this more accurate representation of their effects?
这些其他经典迷幻药一样，都是通过血清素 2A 受体机制起作用。所以我们将它们归为一类。当奥斯蒙德在 20 世纪 50 年代研究这些药物时，他们试图为它们寻找一个更好的名字，因为人们通常称它们为“致精神病药”（psychotomimetics），意思是它们似乎模仿了精神病状态。在研究这些药物并亲自尝试后，他觉得这个标签并不准确。他认为这些药物的影响远不止于此。因此，他和英国作家赫胥黎（Aldous Huxley）一直在反复讨论，试图弄清楚我们该如何称呼这些药物，才能更准确地代表它们的效果。
And, you know, Huxley had famously written about his experience with Mescalan in a book called The Doors of Perception. And eventually they landed on, Osman proposed the word psychedelic because it was meant to characterize that this was a drug that was sort of uncovering something that was in the psyche. It was allowing something in the psyche to manifest or to be revealed. and that was his, you know, using the Greek terminology to sort of come up with a new label. And that really is the beginning of that term specifically back in the 1950s. However, you know, since then, the word psychedelic has been used in so many different ways to talk about artwork, to talk about music, to talk about culture. And so, you know, the very strict sort of pharmacological classification is not always the way that people,
赫胥黎曾有名言，他在《知觉之门》一书中记录了自己使用麦司卡林的经历。最终他们确定了“迷幻药”（psychedelic）这个词，奥斯蒙德提议使用它，因为它是为了表征这种药物揭示了心灵中某种隐藏的东西。它让心灵中的某些东西得以显现或揭示。他利用希腊语词源想出了这个新标签。这确实是该术语在 20 世纪 50 年代初的起源。然而，从那时起，“迷幻”这个词被以各种不同的方式使用，用来谈论艺术品、音乐和文化。因此，那种非常严格的药理学分类并不总是人们在现实生活中谈论这些药物的方式。
people talk about these drugs in real life. And certainly MDMA and even cannabis at times have been sort of lumped in with these psychedelics or drugs that can cause psychedelic-like states, whatever that means. And so MDMA, although it's not exactly the same from a pharmacological standpoint as some of these other classic psychedelics, it does induce a really strong altered state of consciousness, which is one of these key factors that people look at in terms of creating what you'd consider a psychedelic effect. And so people often talk about MDMA as a psychedelic, though it's also been talked about as being an intactogen, for instance,
当然，MDMA 甚至大麻有时也被归入迷幻药或能引起类似迷幻状态的药物中，无论这意味着什么。因此，虽然 MDMA 从药理学角度来看与某些经典迷幻药不完全相同，但它确实能诱导强烈的意识改变状态，这是人们在考虑产生所谓“迷幻效果”时关注的关键因素之一。因此，人们经常将 MDMA 称为迷幻药，尽管它也被称为“移情药”（entactogen），
which means it allows a person to access what's within their mind and their emotional states. So, yeah, there's lots of different ways that we talk about these. And even now, scientists, myself included, are going back and forth talking about, you know, what does psychedelic really mean and what is the definition of psychedelic? medicine. So it's an interesting time because the field, I think, is coming back to grapple with some of these terms and what do they mean. What about the drug ketamine? It's often lumped into the psychedelic category and it's the only one of these drugs that's FDA approved and people can get a prescription for right now. Is ketamine a psychedelic? So ketamine is a slightly different drug.
这意味着它允许一个人接触到他们内心深处和情绪状态。所以，我们谈论这些药物的方式有很多种。即使是现在，包括我在内的科学家们也在反复讨论“迷幻”到底意味着什么，以及“迷幻药”的定义是什么。这是一个有趣的时期，因为我认为该领域正在重新审视这些术语及其含义。那么氯胺酮（ketamine）呢？它经常被归入迷幻药类别，而且它是目前唯一获得 FDA 批准且人们可以获得处方的药物。氯胺酮是迷幻药吗？氯胺酮是一种略有不同的药物。
It's what I would call it a dissociative anesthetic. It's been around for a long time. we use it for anesthesia, you know, in medicine, and both animals and humans all the time is pretty common place. But when you use a sub-anesthetic dose, basically a dose that doesn't knock a person out, they can also have these psychedelic-like states, which include feelings of being outside of one's body and having different types of altered states of consciousness. And again, when you're talking really broadly about a drug that can create an altered state, that's usually the sort of loose usage of that word psychedelic. And so people talk about doing, for instance, psychedelic therapy using ketamine. But when you're doing that, you know, the, again, the pharmacological mechanisms are
我会称它为“解离性麻醉剂”。它已经存在很长时间了。我们在医学上一直使用它进行麻醉，在动物和人类身上都很常见。但当你使用亚麻醉剂量时，也就是不会让人失去知觉的剂量，人们也会产生这些类似迷幻的状态，包括感觉自己脱离了身体，以及产生不同类型的意识改变状态。同样，当你非常宽泛地谈论一种能产生意识改变状态的药物时，通常会用到“迷幻”这个词。因此，人们谈论使用氯胺酮进行迷幻疗法。但当你这样做时，药理机制
slightly different than they are from the class of psychedelics or from MDMA. So is ketamine operating on the same part of the brain or someplace, so it's someplace different in the brain? Well, the mechanism behind the drug action is more rooted in the glutametergic system and the specific NMDA receptors that are part of the glutamate system. So we know that that seems to be one of the targets for these drugs that's slightly different from the classic psychedelics that work more in a serotonin system. But ultimately, you know, we're talking about the same brain and the same brain networks, and they end up having quite a bit of overlap, it seems, in terms of the type of effects
与经典迷幻药或 MDMA 略有不同。那么氯胺酮是在大脑的同一部位起作用，还是在其他地方？嗯，该药物作用背后的机制更多地植根于谷氨酸能系统和作为谷氨酸系统一部分的特定 NMDA 受体。我们知道，这似乎是这些药物的目标之一，与主要在血清素系统中起作用的经典迷幻药略有不同。但归根结底，我们谈论的是同一个大脑和同一个大脑网络，在人们处于药物影响下所经历的效果类型方面，它们似乎有相当多的重叠。
that people are experiencing when they're under the influence. And so, for instance, one of the types of experiences that people often will talk about when they have either sub-anesthetic ketamine dosing or dosing with a classic psychedelic is this unitive state, this feeling of the boundaries between self and other sort of coming down and feeling more interconnected with the world. And those types of experiences can be occasioned both by the classic psychedelics, but as well as ketamine and other types of practices like meditation. and so forth. Has the huge uptick in public interest in psychedelics over the past few years come as a surprise to you? And has doing work in this area changed over the last decade? So I would say yes. I think it's been a little bit surprising to see how enthusiastic popular culture has become about all the work that's happening in this field.
例如，人们在接受亚麻醉剂量氯胺酮或经典迷幻药时经常谈论的一种体验是“统一状态”，即自我与他人之间的界限感消失，感觉与世界更加互联。这些类型的体验既可以由经典迷幻药引起，也可以由氯胺酮以及冥想等其他类型的练习引起。过去几年公众对迷幻药的兴趣激增，这让你感到惊讶吗？在这一领域工作在过去十年中发生了变化吗？我会说是的。看到大众文化对该领域正在进行的所有工作变得如此热情，确实有点令人惊讶。
And, you know, the prospects of psychedelic therapies, I think, you know, many people would have said 10 years ago that, you know, they would have been skeptical about sort of widespread adoption of this type of treatment in a medical setting. And nowadays, it seems almost imminent. And actually, with MDMA, we will be seeing that in practice, you know, in the U.S. as early as next year. And then, as you mentioned, ketamine is already available. And there is growing interest in using ketamine in this way because it's not something that had been practiced, you know, in a widespread fashion to be doing this type of ketamine therapy. Only until recently did there become, again, growing interest in market for something like that. And so now you're seeing the growth of that to provide those types of services from different companies out there. So what are the mental disorders that psychedelics can treat?
我认为，十年前很多人会对在医疗环境中广泛采用这种疗法持怀疑态度。而如今，这似乎已迫在眉睫。事实上，对于 MDMA，我们最早将于明年在美国看到其实际应用。正如你提到的，氯胺酮已经可以使用了。人们对以这种方式使用氯胺酮的兴趣日益浓厚，因为这并不是一种被广泛实践的疗法。直到最近，人们对这类疗法的市场兴趣才开始增长。所以现在你看到各种公司都在提供这类服务。那么迷幻药可以治疗哪些精神障碍呢？
I mentioned in the intro that Australia approved treatments for depression and post-traumatic stress disorder. Is that where the evidence is the strongest at this point? Yeah. So there's been a lot of work. It sort of started, again, with the classic psychedelics back in the 1950s and 60s. You saw a good amount of research. Then that sort of died down for some time after backlash and criminalization in the 1970s. But really, since the late 90s, early 2000s, you start to see.
我在开场白中提到澳大利亚批准了治疗抑郁症和创伤后应激障碍的疗法。这是目前证据最充分的领域吗？是的。已经有很多研究了。它始于 20 世纪 50 年代和 60 年代的经典迷幻药研究。在 20 世纪 70 年代遭到抵制和定罪后，研究沉寂了一段时间。但实际上，从 90 年代末和 21 世纪初开始，你开始看到
another uptick in research. And yeah, you noted a couple of different conditions. So the ones that are very close to approval for, for instance, MDMA is use of MDMA with talk therapy for post-traumatic stress disorder, PTSD. And so that's actually undergone two phase three clinical trials now that were sponsored by the Multidisciplinary Association for Psychedelic Studies, MAPS, and, And in both of those studies, although the second study has not yet been published, the results have been overwhelmingly positive. And they found a lot of remission of symptoms and improvement in mental health status in these folks who were going through the study.
研究再次回升。是的，你提到了几种不同的疾病。例如，MDMA 与谈话疗法结合治疗创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）已非常接近获批。这实际上已经完成了两项三期临床试验，由多学科迷幻药研究协会（MAPS）赞助。在这两项研究中，尽管第二项研究尚未发表，但结果非常积极。他们发现，在参与研究的患者中，症状得到了很大程度的缓解，心理健康状况也有所改善。
They're getting, I believe it was three doses of MDMA during the course of treatment, which lasts about 12 weeks. And there's preparation before and after the drug is administered. and, you know, in the intervening weeks, there's often different types of counseling or talk therapy going on. And the people who are getting those types of treatments versus placebo are showing a far greater response rate. And so you're seeing a majority of people who get that MDMA therapy with PTSD are improving above and beyond what they would be doing with just the talk therapy alone. And so those are the types of data that are necessary in order to get a medical approval through the FTC. And at this point, you see that is, again, very close with MDMA. And so by next year, it's seeming as though you're going to see a change in the classification of MDMA.
我相信他们在 12 周的治疗过程中接受了三次 MDMA 给药。在给药前后都有准备工作，在中间的几周里，通常会进行不同类型的咨询或谈话疗法。与安慰剂组相比，接受这些治疗的人表现出更高的反应率。因此，大多数接受 MDMA 治疗 PTSD 的人，其改善程度远超仅进行谈话疗法的情况。这些就是获得 FDA 医疗批准所必需的数据。目前，MDMA 已经非常接近获批。因此，到明年，我们似乎会看到 MDMA 的分类发生变化。
So it's no longer considered Schedule 1, but it can be prescribed by physicians and clinicians who want to use it to help people with PTSD. And, yeah, that's where I would say most of the evidence with MDMA therapy has been focused so far. Other folks are working on looking at MDMA and treating things like substance use disorders or other types of mental health conditions. But so far, yeah, PTSD has been the big one. So what's happening in people's brains, say, if you're taking MDMA for a substance use disorder? I mean, why would that work as opposed to any of the other treatments that are out there right now? I mean, what's the difference between that and say antibuse? Well, antibuse is definitely not one of these drugs as well-tobuse.
它将不再被视为一级管制药物，而是可以由希望用它来帮助 PTSD 患者的医生和临床医生开具处方。是的，这就是我认为目前 MDMA 疗法证据最集中的地方。其他人正在研究 MDMA 在治疗物质使用障碍或其他心理健康状况方面的应用。但到目前为止，PTSD 是最主要的领域。那么，如果一个人因物质使用障碍而服用 MDMA，他们的大脑中会发生什么？我的意思是，为什么这比目前现有的任何其他疗法都有效？这与戒酒硫（Antabuse）有什么区别？嗯，戒酒硫绝对不是这些药物之一。
People don't usually like to use it because, you know, if they just, if they want to drink, then they just stop taking the medicine. And, you know, there's lots of different types of substance use disorders and treatments for those that vary widely. But what I think sets apart these psychedelic therapies is that usually with a course of talk therapy and somewhere in between one and three drug administrations over the course of a few months, you're usually able to help people move. beyond sort of not just the problematic behavior, which would be, for instance, you know, alcohol or drug use, but often to kind of get to the root of the issue to psychologically work through some of the presenting problems that are related to the reasons why they use those substances to begin with. And so I think a lot of current treatments are focused on masking things like withdrawal or craving or trying to keep people so that they're able to avoid, using the drug sort of on a very surface level, but when you start to go down into the deeper roots of why it is that they're doing those types of behaviors, then you're able to really make long-term lasting changes. In terms of, you know, what are they doing in the brain? That's still
人们通常不喜欢使用它，因为如果他们想喝酒，他们就会停止服药。物质使用障碍及其治疗方法多种多样。但我认为这些迷幻疗法的独特之处在于，通常通过一个疗程的谈话疗法，并在几个月内进行一到三次药物给药，你通常能够帮助人们超越单纯的问题行为（例如酒精或药物使用），并深入问题的根源，从心理上解决与他们最初使用这些物质的原因相关的潜在问题。我认为目前的许多疗法侧重于掩盖戒断或渴望等症状，或者试图让人们在表面上避免使用药物，但当你开始深入挖掘他们产生这些行为的根源时，你就能真正实现长期持久的改变。至于它们在大脑中做了什么，那仍然
really a big mystery, I would say. We've seen a lot more research over the last decade or so looking at psychedelics and MDMA to understand their brain mechanisms, but we're really still unpacking those and trying to differentiate what the different types of drugs are doing and why they have the impact that they do, meaning that you're seeing long-term changes, including things like, you know, months or later, people are still showing improvements, which is not the case with a drug like Antibuse, for instance, or like SSRI standard antidepressant, because when you stop taking those and they stop working. How much is known about how these drugs are helping people where other treatments don't?
是一个巨大的谜。在过去十年左右的时间里，我们看到了更多关于迷幻药和 MDMA 的研究，以了解它们的大脑机制，但我们仍在解析这些机制，并试图区分不同类型的药物及其产生影响的原因，这意味着你看到了长期的变化，包括几个月后人们仍表现出改善，这与戒酒硫或标准 SSRI 抗抑郁药的情况不同，因为当你停止服用这些药物时，它们就不再起作用了。关于这些药物如何在其他疗法无效的情况下帮助人们，我们了解多少？
for example, using psilocybin to treat persistent depression? So that's actually an area has been an active study, and particularly with psilocybin, as you noted, you know, that's well far along in terms of studying that as an antidepressant treatment, both in people with major depression, but also in people with treatment-resistant major depression, which is a person who's failed multiple different, you know, failed to improve after taking multiple different types of treatments or medications. And so, yeah, those cases, you know, are usually thought of as being a little more serious because people are not responding to the traditional therapies and treatments that are available. And so in those cases, what they found is that, you know, in a nice, large study that was published, this is actually the biggest study published on psilocybin so far.
例如，使用裸盖菇素治疗持续性抑郁症？这是一个活跃的研究领域，特别是裸盖菇素，正如你所指出的，作为一种抗抑郁治疗，它在重度抑郁症患者以及治疗抵抗性重度抑郁症患者（即在尝试多种不同疗法或药物后未能改善的患者）中的研究已经相当深入。因此，这些病例通常被认为更严重，因为患者对现有的传统疗法没有反应。在这些病例中，他们发现，在一项发表的大型研究中（这是迄今为止关于裸盖菇素发表的最大规模研究），
And it was about 230 people or so with treatment resistant depression. and they either got one high dose of psilocybin, which is 25 milligrams, or they got 10 milligrams of psilocybin, which is a moderately low dose, or they got a placebo-like dose of one milligram of psilocybin that usually doesn't have much of an effect. And they were able to see that the people who got that single high dose were showing improvements in their depression on average. It lasted out to three weeks after the drug. And again, that's, you know, first, different in a couple of ways from our standard treatments. First, you know, those people are getting symptom improvements immediately after they've gotten the drug dose. And that's different than a lot of our standard antidepressant medicines that usually take weeks to start working. And the other thing is these are people who had already failed to respond to other types of medications,
大约 230 名患有治疗抵抗性抑郁症的人参与了研究。他们要么接受了一次 25 毫克的高剂量裸盖菇素，要么接受了 10 毫克的低剂量裸盖菇素，要么接受了 1 毫克的安慰剂剂量（通常没有太大效果）。他们能够看到，接受单次高剂量治疗的人在抑郁症方面表现出平均改善。这种改善持续到给药后三周。这与我们的标准疗法有几点不同。首先，这些人在给药后立即获得了症状改善。这与我们许多通常需要数周才能开始起效的标准抗抑郁药物不同。另一件事是，这些人之前已经对其他类型的药物没有反应，
and yet they are still seeing these improvements in their depression that last weeks after. the single dosing. And, you know, that's not even taking into account other studies like ours here at Hopkins where people got two doses and are showing symptom remission and improvements that last up to a year later. And so really, that is exciting because for a lot of people who are not responding to current treatments, you know, we need something new. We need something that works better.
然而他们仍然看到了持续数周的抑郁改善。这甚至还没有考虑到我们霍普金斯大学的其他研究，人们接受了两次给药，症状缓解和改善持续了一年之久。这确实令人兴奋，因为对于许多对现有疗法没有反应的人来说，我们需要新的东西。我们需要更有效的东西。
And the idea that you could take one or a few doses of this drug and, you know, supplement that with some talk therapy and see these long-lasting benefits is in many ways revolutionary for the field. Are there certain people who should not take psychedelics for problems that they have? For example, I've read that these drugs could be harmful to people with bipolar disorder. Why is that? There's concerns, and there have been case studies and other data from people who have used these psychedelics out in the world, who have then gone on. to develop manic symptoms, you know, and that obviously can be problematic. We don't want to,
这种只需服用一剂或几剂药物，辅以一些谈话疗法，就能看到长期益处的想法，在许多方面对该领域来说是革命性的。是否有些人不应该服用迷幻药来解决他们的问题？例如，我读到这些药物可能对双相情感障碍患者有害。为什么会这样？确实存在担忧，并且有案例研究和其他数据表明，在世界各地使用这些迷幻药的人，后来出现了躁狂症状，这显然是有问题的。我们不想
you know, put anyone on a course where their mental health status is going to deteriorate after you give them a high dose of the drug. And so, you know, that's been one area where people have been very careful and excluding folks who have bipolar mood. However, there are preliminary data showing that people who get psilocybin who have a milder form of bipolar mood, seem to respond well and have not seen these incidents of mania. However, you still get the case reports from people out in the community who have had those types of situations. And so obviously, it's still an open question.
让任何人在服用高剂量药物后心理健康状况恶化。因此，这是人们一直非常谨慎的一个领域，排除了患有双相情感障碍的人。然而，有初步数据表明，患有较轻微双相情感障碍的裸盖菇素使用者似乎反应良好，并没有出现躁狂发作。不过，你仍然会从社区中听到出现这种情况的案例报告。所以显然，这仍然是一个悬而未决的问题。
And it's an area that I think requires more study. The main area that we know that, you know, people who receive high-dose psychedelics may have lasting problems afterwards would be people who have a predisposition to psychotic illness, schizophrenia, those types of conditions. If they either have a personal or family history of one of those disorders or if they've, you know, had symptoms of that type of condition, we would often screen those people out of our research studies, mainly because you would be, again, trying to avoid precipitating ongoing problems, including things like psychotic symptoms that can last, you know, for months or longer if, you know, things don't go the way
我认为这是一个需要更多研究的领域。我们知道服用高剂量迷幻药后可能会产生持久问题的最主要人群是那些有精神病倾向、精神分裂症等疾病的人。如果他们有个人或家族病史，或者如果他们有这类疾病的症状，我们通常会将这些人排除在研究之外，主要是因为你要避免诱发持续的问题，包括如果事情没有按预期发展，可能会持续数月甚至更久的精神病症状。
that we want them to. Some of the people who are listening to this may themselves be experiencing some syndromes where they think that these kinds of drugs might be helpful to them. And where does the average person go to participate? Say it's got to be a clinical trial at this point, right? I mean, because most of this stuff is not approved for general use. Right. Well, I mean, there are many people who are trying to self-treat or to find treatment
一些听众可能正在经历某些综合征，他们认为这些药物可能对他们有帮助。普通人去哪里参与研究？目前必须是临床试验，对吧？因为大多数药物尚未获批用于一般用途。是的。嗯，有很多人试图自我治疗或寻找地下治疗，
underground, that even in places where legalization or decriminalization might have occurred, that's still illegal at the federal level. So, you know, there are penalties for that, criminal penalties and other things that can happen that are problematic. But in terms of, you know, finding something legally available in the U.S., particularly, yeah, you'd want to go to a website called clinicaltrials.gov. And that's, you know, a registry where all the clinical trials that are happening, both here and abroad are listed out.
即使在已经实现合法化或非刑事化的地方，这在联邦层面仍然是非法的。因此，这会带来刑事处罚和其他可能出现的问题。但就如何在美国合法获得治疗而言，你确实需要访问 clinicaltrials.gov 网站。这是一个注册中心，列出了国内外正在进行的所有临床试验。
You can look by condition. You can look by keywords such as SILA simon, for instance. You can look by location and try to find things that are available. I would say even though the work is growing, there's still just a few hub regions where you can get a lot of research happening. And otherwise, you know, there's a lot of folks who not necessarily have access because either the work is not happening near them, or the clinical trial inclusion criteria are very strict, which they tend to be, you know, primarily for safety safety.
你可以按疾病搜索。你可以按关键词（例如“裸盖菇素”）搜索。你可以按地点搜索，并尝试找到可用的项目。我想说，尽管研究工作在增长，但目前只有少数几个中心区域有大量的研究在进行。否则，很多人可能无法获得机会，因为研究不在他们附近，或者临床试验的纳入标准非常严格（主要是为了安全）。
Sure. So what's the outlook for these drugs being approved as medications in the U.S.? You mentioned MDMA seems close, but what about psilocybin? What about some of the others that you mentioned, DMT, that comes from ayahuasca, things like that? Well, psilocybin is probably the next closest to approval, I would say, because there's, There's been such a preponderance of research looking at it for depression and then also for other conditions like substance use and existential distress. And so my forecast, if you will, would be that within the next three or four years, you'll likely see psilocybin getting into that approval process with the FDA as a new treatment, something that will be then accessible to people who are able to get psilocybin treatment by a licensed clinician, particularly for things like. major depression, which is where, again, a lot of the data have been so far. There's not a lot of
当然。那么这些药物在美国被批准为药物的前景如何？你提到 MDMA 似乎很接近，但裸盖菇素呢？你提到的其他药物，如 DMT（来自死藤水）等呢？嗯，裸盖菇素可能是下一个最接近获批的，因为有大量的研究关注它在抑郁症以及物质使用和存在主义困境等其他疾病中的应用。所以我的预测是，在未来三到四年内，你可能会看到裸盖菇素进入 FDA 的审批流程，成为一种新的治疗方法，届时由持证临床医生提供裸盖菇素治疗，特别是针对重度抑郁症等疾病。目前还没有
widespread study right now of other types of psychedelics, LSD, mescaline, DMT. There's been small studies here and there. The regulatory red tape to do this work, and then also the sort of regular or typical form of medication approval in this country, you know, kind of make it difficult to do this work because between the regulatory approvals and hurdles that we have to get jump through to do this, the enormous cost of doing the research. And then if you're talking about something like LSD, for instance, that's not a patentable molecule because it's been around for so long, then it makes it quite difficult to move it through this process and to get people to invest in that because why would anyone spend money to study it if they can't get a return on investment
对其他类型的迷幻药（LSD、麦司卡林、DMT）进行广泛研究。这里有一些小规模研究。进行这项工作的监管繁文缛节，以及这个国家通常的药物审批形式，使得这项工作变得困难，因为在我们需要跨越的监管审批和障碍之间，研究成本巨大。而且，如果你谈论的是像 LSD 这样的药物，因为它已经存在太久了，所以它不是一种可申请专利的分子，这使得它很难通过这个过程，也很难让人们投资，因为如果他们不能从资本主义的角度获得投资回报，为什么还要花钱去研究它呢？
from a capitalist standpoint. So, yeah. Right. So those are the drug manufacturers, the ones who have the money to go through the process. Correct. But, you know, since they don't own those molecules, then they don't feel compelled to study them. And so that's why you've seen such a long process with something like MDMA or psilocybin, where the funding to do this research has sort of come in piecemeal over the course of literally decades to get it to where we're at with the science.
所以，是的。没错。所以那些是药物制造商，他们有钱走这个流程。没错。但是，由于他们不拥有这些分子，他们就不会感到有动力去研究它们。这就是为什么像 MDMA 或裸盖菇素这样的药物经历了如此漫长的过程，为进行这项研究而筹集的资金在几十年的时间里零星地投入，才使科学发展到今天。
Now, you've written about equity and access issues, both in terms of who is being included in the research trials on these drugs, but also who might have access to the treatments eventually. Can you talk a little bit about that? Yeah. Well, you know, it's been pointed out that many of the research studies that have been published using MDMA or psilocybin have been predominantly white, predominantly high socioeconomic status participants. And there's a number of structural reasons for that. And then there's a number of cultural reasons for that as well, I think. But we'll say I think it's over 85% of participants in the clinical trials that to date have occurred using psilocybin and MDMA have been white. And if you want to kind of think about why is that, you know, some of those structural reasons that I mentioned include things, factors such as just not being able to get off of work,
现在，你写过关于公平和准入问题的文章，既包括谁被纳入了这些药物的研究试验，也包括谁最终可能获得这些治疗。你能谈谈这一点吗？是的。嗯，有人指出，许多已发表的关于 MDMA 或裸盖菇素的研究，参与者主要是白人，且主要是高社会经济地位人群。这背后有许多结构性原因，我认为也有许多文化原因。但我认为，迄今为止，在裸盖菇素和 MDMA 的临床试验中，超过 85% 的参与者是白人。如果你想思考为什么会这样，我提到的那些结构性原因包括一些因素，比如无法请假，
spend a whole day in a therapy session like this and, you know, being able to do that multiple times or not being able to get away from child care or domestic issues that have to be taken care of. So that, you know, that's one thing that I think is really skewed this work in a certain way. Culturally, I also think that there's a lot of mistrust of the medical institutions and biomedical research for a number of reasons, historic abuses, things of that nature that, you know, I think make people mistrustful of coming to do a study where you're going to take a drug that if you, you know, have read popular media, you might think, well, this drug might make me go crazy or this drug, you know, is going to make me feel really strange. And I don't know who,
花一整天时间进行这样的治疗，或者无法多次这样做，或者无法摆脱育儿或必须处理的家庭问题。所以，我认为这确实在某种程度上扭曲了这项工作。在文化上，我也认为由于历史上的虐待等原因，人们对医疗机构和生物医学研究存在很多不信任，我认为这使得人们不愿参加一项研究，因为如果你读过大众媒体，你可能会认为，这种药物可能会让我发疯，或者这种药物会让我感觉非常奇怪。我不知道谁
you know, who's going to be around me or what's going to happen or what are they going to do to me. And so I think that can be a really very real concern for people, not to mention, you know, the years and years of criminalization and stigmatization of drugs and drug use in general that make people probably raise an eyebrown and say, you know, they want to take me into the laboratory and give me this illegal drug. I don't know if I'm comfortable with that. And so, you know, I think that's a big problem with psychedelic research to this point is that it has been predominantly white, predominantly high or socioeconomic status participants. But, you know, this is something that actually, you know, is parallel in all sorts of biomedical research. And so
会在我身边，或者会发生什么，或者他们会对我不利。所以我认为这对人们来说是一个非常现实的担忧，更不用说多年来对药物和药物使用的定罪和污名化，这让人们可能会挑起眉毛说，他们想把我带进实验室并给我这种非法药物。我不知道我是否对此感到舒服。所以，我认为这是迄今为止迷幻药研究的一个大问题，即参与者主要是白人，主要是高社会经济地位人群。但是，这实际上在各种生物医学研究中都是平行的。所以
it does point to these bigger problems, which is, you know, you see less than 5% of people who are in trials of new FDA-approved medications in the 90s and 2000s were coming from black, African-American, Hispanic backgrounds. And so you're seeing, again, a very homogeneous population in many of these studies for any sort of medical research. And that's a problem. And the other problem, I think, at another level, is that many of the researchers themselves are not representative of the broader community. And so you see less than 5% of the researchers doing these studies are coming from a black, African-American, Hispanic, indigenous background. And so that also, I think, would make people hesitant to necessarily
这确实指向了这些更大的问题，即在 90 年代和 2000 年代 FDA 批准的新药试验中，不到 5% 的参与者来自黑人、非裔美国人、西班牙裔背景。所以你再次看到，在许多此类医学研究中，人群非常单一。这是一个问题。我认为在另一个层面上，另一个问题是许多研究人员本身并不代表更广泛的社区。因此，进行这些研究的研究人员中，不到 5% 来自黑人、非裔美国人、西班牙裔、原住民背景。因此，我认为这也会使人们犹豫不决，不一定
want to come in and feel invested to do this type of thing. So, you know, there's, there's I think many different layers there to be unpacked. But ultimately, you know, I'm hoping that both the researchers and the participants are able to diversify over the next decade. And that also, you know, should this type of treatment be approved soon, that we're going to find ways to make that available and accessible to people, particularly people who are coming from lower SCS backgrounds because they often have big health disparities and issues that they need to to deal with that include many of the types of problems that we're talking about, post-traumatic stress, substance use, depression, and so on.
想要参与并感到有动力去做这类事情。所以，我认为这里有很多不同的层面需要解析。但归根结底，我希望在未来十年内，研究人员和参与者都能实现多元化。而且，如果这种疗法很快获批，我们也将找到方法使其对人们可用和可及，特别是那些来自低社会经济地位背景的人，因为他们通常面临巨大的健康差异和需要解决的问题，包括我们正在谈论的许多类型的问题，创伤后应激、物质使用、抑郁症等等。
Oh, that all makes sense. I want to change gears a little bit and talk about microdosing, which is taking small amounts of some of these drugs on a regular basis to treat a variety of issues. Now, proponents say that taking tiny doses of psychedelics that are too small to have real psychedelic effects can help with mood, creativity, productivity, and all sorts of things. Is there any research that backs this up? Not really. So, I should say there's not really a lot of research to begin with.
哦，这一切都说得通。我想换个话题，谈谈“微剂量给药”（microdosing），即定期服用少量这些药物来治疗各种问题。支持者说，服用太小而不会产生真正迷幻效果的微量迷幻药，可以帮助改善情绪、创造力、生产力以及各种事情。有任何研究支持这一点吗？并没有。所以，我应该说，首先并没有太多的研究。
Most of what we have is anecdotal. And you can collect anecdotal data from lots of people, and this has been done both sort of retrospectively and prospectively. But, you know, there haven't been a lot of well-controlled trials. There's only been a few small studies of microdosing in psilocybin and LSD. They haven't shown anything that, to me, shows a clear signal of benefit. More than anything, what I imagine we're seeing often is some sort of placebo effect where people know they're taking something and they feel like they're feeling better as a result,
我们拥有的大部分是轶事证据。你可以从很多人那里收集轶事数据，这在回顾性和前瞻性方面都已经做过了。但是，并没有进行过很多控制良好的试验。关于裸盖菇素和 LSD 的微剂量给药只有几项小规模研究。它们没有显示出任何对我来说显示出明确益处的信号。比起其他任何事情，我想我们经常看到的是某种安慰剂效应，人们知道他们在服用某种东西，结果他们觉得自己的感觉变好了，
whether or not the substance is doing something. Now, I do think that there's a real possibility for microdosing to have therapeutic benefit, it, but it's really hard and expensive to study it properly, to do a double-blind placebo control study, for instance, in dozens or even, you know, hundreds of people to actually test this out. And so until that happens, I would say the jury is out, you know, we don't really have a good answer. I've certainly spoken to lots of people with very convincing anecdotal reports of getting better from all sorts of different conditions, from using micro doses of psilocybin, for instance. But, you know, nobody's actually drilled down into a cohort of someone,
无论这种物质是否真的在起作用。现在，我确实认为微剂量给药有产生治疗益处的真正可能性，但要正确研究它非常困难且昂贵，例如在几十甚至几百人中进行双盲安慰剂对照研究来实际测试这一点。所以在那之前，我会说陪审团还没有定论，我们并没有一个好的答案。我当然和很多人谈过，他们有非常令人信服的轶事报告，说通过使用微剂量的裸盖菇素等改善了各种不同的疾病。但是，没有人真正深入研究过某个人群，
of people, for instance, with major depression and studied this carefully. And so until that happens, I think we can't really make a conclusive statement. Would you say that it's dangerous for people to engage in microdosing? I mean, people are able to get their hands on some of these drugs and sort of do it themselves at home. I mean, is that a good thing? I mean, I wouldn't advocate for that. I mean, it's illegal. People have lost their jobs, for doing that kind of thing. You know, depending on what you're taking, it can be really hard to tell what it is that you have. If you're talking about, for instance, a synthetic molecule like LSD, you may be getting something very different than what you think you're getting, which could have significant adverse health effects.
例如，针对重度抑郁症患者进行了仔细研究。因此，在这些研究完成之前，我认为我们无法做出定论。你会说人们进行微剂量给药是危险的吗？我的意思是，人们能够接触到其中一些药物，并在家里自行尝试。这算是一件好事吗？我不会提倡这样做。这是违法的。人们因为做这种事而丢了工作。你知道，取决于你服用的是什么，很难判断你到底拿到了什么。如果你指的是像LSD这样的合成分子，你得到的可能与你认为的完全不同，这可能会产生严重的健康副作用。
With psilocybin mushrooms, you know, that's something that people can find because they grow out in the world. And, you know, the only thing I would say there is you may not have the types of mushrooms you think. you have and, you know, obviously measurement can be difficult, but otherwise, I would say that the classic psychedelics, if you know what you have and how much you're taking, they're relatively safe for most people. And that's, you know, due to the fact that they don't really cause any toxic effects on our major organ systems. And so taking small amounts of them shouldn't be problematic. Although there, again, a lot of open questions. You know, people have talked about serotonin-2B receptor properties of psilocybin, for instance, and how that can cause heart valve problems.
对于裸盖菇素蘑菇，你知道，这是人们可以找到的东西，因为它们生长在野外。我唯一要说的是，你可能并没有得到你认为的那种蘑菇，而且显然测量可能很困难。但除此之外，我会说经典的迷幻药，如果你知道你拥有的是什么以及服用的剂量，它们对大多数人来说是相对安全的。这是因为它们实际上不会对我们的主要器官系统造成任何毒性影响。因此，服用少量应该不会有问题。尽管如此，仍然有很多悬而未决的问题。例如，人们讨论过裸盖菇素的血清素-2B受体特性，以及它如何导致心脏瓣膜问题。
And that actually was related to a medication called fenfin that was being used for weight loss years ago. It was pulled from the market because of those same heart valve problems. And when you take psilocybin treatment, for instance, with one high dose, you wouldn't have to worry about that because it's not a chronic dosing regimen. But if you're taking that often over and over again, that does lead to potential, for instance, to develop some of these problems. So again, there's still a lot we don't know.
这实际上与多年前用于减肥的一种名为芬氟拉明（fen-phen）的药物有关。它因为同样的心脏瓣膜问题被撤出市场。当你进行裸盖菇素治疗时，例如一次高剂量，你就不必担心这个问题，因为它不是长期的给药方案。但如果你经常反复服用，那确实会导致产生这些问题的潜在风险。所以，我们仍然有很多未知之处。
And so I would certainly, again, not advocate for that type of treatment, but certainly there's a lot of people who, you know, feel desperate and, you know, they're looking for something to help them. And I can understand that, you know, based on where we're at with limited treatment options, that people are exploring all sorts of different things. Do you worry that some of these psychedelics are being overhyped or advertised directly to the public, for example, there was an opinion piece in the New York Times recently headlined,
因此，我当然不会提倡那种治疗方式，但确实有很多人感到绝望，他们在寻找能帮助他们的东西。我能理解，鉴于我们目前治疗选择有限，人们正在探索各种不同的事物。你是否担心其中一些迷幻药被过度炒作或直接向公众宣传？例如，最近《纽约时报》有一篇评论文章，标题是：
why are ketamine ads following me around the internet? And it was about how ketamine is being pushed, you know, by targeted social media ads. Is this a problem? I think it can be, yeah. I mean, you know, just us right now having these conversations, you know, it's likely that we may get one of those ads pop up later on our own social media. But, you know, what I do think is that there has been a significant overhype of what's going on with the science.
为什么氯胺酮广告在互联网上跟踪我？文章讲述了氯胺酮是如何通过定向社交媒体广告进行推广的。这是一个问题吗？我认为是的。我的意思是，就在我们现在进行这些对话时，我们很可能会在自己的社交媒体上看到其中一个广告弹出。但我确实认为，科学界正在发生的事情被严重过度炒作了。
Yes, these drugs seem to have a remarkable therapeutic potentials. And yes, for many years, they've been stigmatized and talked about as this sort of, you know, really dangerous drugs of abuse. But, you know, flipping the script and saying, you know, these are a panacea, you know, these are going to save the world, you know, because and that was a. headline directly pull for Roman Stone, you know, can psychedelic save the world? You know, that type of sensationalism, I don't think is helpful for the general public to be consuming and particularly for vulnerable populations, including people who are struggling with mental health conditions to, you know, see that type of media and then, you know, not really know what is the state of the science because, again, often it's overblown. We know that ketamine has significant
是的，这些药物似乎具有显著的治疗潜力。是的，多年来，它们一直被污名化，被视为那种非常危险的滥用药物。但是，扭转局面并说这些是万灵药，它们将拯救世界（这标题直接摘自《滚石》杂志，迷幻药能拯救世界吗？），这种耸人听闻的报道，我认为对公众消费没有帮助，特别是对于包括正在与心理健康状况作斗争的弱势群体在内的人们来说，看到这类媒体报道，却不真正了解科学现状，因为这些报道往往被夸大了。我们知道氯胺酮具有显著的
antidepressant effects. I mean, we've known that for a long time now. And so if people can get access to it and they have serious depression, they can get often relief from that, you know, in a ketamine treatment setting. But, you know, when you're starting to go out and try to market that or basically sell that to people aggressively, yeah, I think you're running up against some real potential ethical issues. So what avenues of research are you finding the most exciting right now?
抗抑郁作用。我们很早就知道了。因此，如果人们能够获得它，并且患有严重的抑郁症，他们通常可以在氯胺酮治疗环境中获得缓解。但是，当你开始尝试营销它，或者基本上积极地向人们推销它时，我认为你正面临一些真正的潜在伦理问题。那么，你目前觉得哪些研究方向最令人兴奋？
I'm excited by the prospect of medical approvals by FDA in the next few years because I do think that's really going to revolutionize the landscape of mental health care in this country. I think that it's going to change the model somewhat from what it has been, where we had sort of top therapy siphoned off on one side and then pharmacotherapy or medications on the other side and sometimes people would be doing both, but often not in an integrated fashion. And what's nice about these treatments is that they bring both together in a comprehensive package and the psychedelic treatments themselves are so different than what's available right now. And why I say that is because, as we discussed earlier, you know, they really kind of bring you into yourself
我对未来几年获得FDA医疗批准的前景感到兴奋，因为我确实认为这将彻底改变我国心理健康护理的格局。我认为它将在某种程度上改变现有的模式，即过去我们将谈话疗法放在一边，将药物治疗放在另一边，有时人们会同时进行，但往往不是以整合的方式。这些治疗方法的优点在于它们将两者结合在一个综合方案中，而且迷幻药治疗本身与目前可用的治疗方法非常不同。我之所以这么说，是因为正如我们之前讨论的那样，它们确实让你深入了解自己，
and what it is is the root of your issues, whether that be relationship problems, past trauma, you know, issues that you have with self-esteem, you know, all these different types of things that can be wrapped up in, you know, a mental health diagnosis can be sort of unraveled somewhat during the process of this time, this kind of psychedelic therapy, and then allow people to really resolve them and not just to sort of cover them over with the standard types of therapies that we have available right now. And you can't often do that in talk therapies, obviously, over the course of the long period of time. But we usually will have our walls up and our defenses there to try to keep things
了解你问题的根源，无论是人际关系问题、过去的创伤，还是自尊心问题，所有这些可能被包裹在心理健康诊断中的不同类型的问题，都可以在这种迷幻疗法的过程中得到某种程度的解开，从而让人们真正解决它们，而不仅仅是用我们目前可用的标准疗法来掩盖它们。显然，在长时间的谈话疗法中，你通常无法做到这一点。我们通常会竖起高墙和防御机制，试图阻止事情
from changing too fast because that can feel very threatening and scary. But with psychedelics, it can kind of allow us to make a very deep dive very quickly. So I think that's most exciting to me. But with the research, you know, you're just seeing more and more research branching out. And so, for instance, you know, we're starting to do research. now with psilocybin and patients with early stage Alzheimer's disease here. My colleague, Dr. Nali Gukassian is working on a nice study that she's just wrapping up in psilocybin and people with anorexia nervosa. So starting to look at these different areas where we are in clear need
变化得太快，因为那会让人感到非常有威胁和恐惧。但有了迷幻药，它可以让我们非常迅速地进行深度挖掘。所以我认为这对我来说最令人兴奋。但在研究方面，你看到越来越多的研究在分支。例如，我们现在开始对早期阿尔茨海默病患者进行裸盖菇素的研究。我的同事Nali Gukassian博士正在进行一项很好的研究，她即将完成关于裸盖菇素在神经性厌食症患者中的应用。所以开始关注这些我们明显需要
of knee treatments and exploring the potentials there, you know, I think is also really exciting because it's a new horizon for us. We've actually known for a long time that we've actually known for a long time that we could use psychedelics to use to treat addictions, existential distress, and, you know, because it was being done back in the 60s. But now we're kind of getting back to the place where we can reestablish that using rigorous and contemporary research methods. But now there's all these other questions that are on the horizon, including, you know, those new clinical conditions on the one hand, but then also the biological and psychological mechanisms that underlie these drug effects because it is a mystery. You know, we talk about how the brain is reacting to these drugs,
新治疗方法的领域并探索其中的潜力，我认为也非常令人兴奋，因为这对我们来说是一个新的视野。我们其实早就知道，我们早就知道可以使用迷幻药来治疗成瘾、存在主义困境，因为这在60年代就已经在做了。但现在我们正在回到那个位置，即利用严谨和现代的研究方法重新建立它。但现在地平线上还有所有其他问题，一方面是那些新的临床状况，另一方面是这些药物作用背后的生物学和心理学机制，因为这是一个谜。我们谈论大脑如何对这些药物做出反应，
but it's more than just how is the brain responding. It's how is the mind responding because that's where you start to see changes in the sense of self-identity, for instance, in a person who's been struggling for years who identifies as a person with a problem with particular substance, for instance, and is able to change that sense of identity in a way that allows them to live the rest of their lives in a healthier way. And so that, you know, I find unique among all the different types of treatments that are out there. Well, Dr. Garcia-Rameo, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting.
但这不仅仅是大脑如何反应的问题。这是心灵如何反应的问题，因为那是你开始看到自我认同发生变化的地方。例如，一个多年来一直在挣扎的人，他将自己定义为一个有特定物质问题的人，能够以一种让他们在余生中以更健康的方式生活的方式改变这种认同感。因此，我认为这在所有现有的治疗方法中是独一无二的。好的，Garcia-Rameo博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣。
I think what you're doing is very exciting, and we will stay tuned. Yeah, well, thanks so much for having me. I really appreciate it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. And again, we'd like to hear from you about what you think of this podcast and what you'd like to hear more from us. So please go to our website, www.spicingsychology.org, and look for the link to our listener's survey.
我认为你所做的事情非常令人兴奋，我们会持续关注。是的，非常感谢邀请我。我真的很感激。你可以在我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher、YouTube或任何你获取播客的地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请给我们留下评论。再次强调，我们很想听听你对这个播客的看法，以及你希望听到我们更多关于什么的内容。所以请访问我们的网站www.speakingofpsychology.org，并寻找听众调查的链接。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. The American Psychological Association. Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由Lee Winerman制作。我们的声音编辑是Chris Condayan。感谢收听。美国心理学会。Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。